♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
GOT TO BE HONEST NOT MANY OF
US IN THE PRESS ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE 2020
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
JUST HOURS AGO IT FELT LIKE
IT WAS GOING TO BE AN
EXHAUSTING MISERABLE AFFAIR.
THE CURRENT FIELD IS A
MIXTURE OF FOSSILS,
EXTREMISTS AND POWER HUNGRY
CYNICS WILLING TO SAY
ANYTHING AND HURT ANYBODY TO
GET A HOLD ON THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
A NEW CANDIDATE HAS ENTERED
THE RACE A MAN UNTETHERED
FROM THE OLD WAYS.
POSSIBLY EVEN FROM THE
CONVENTIONAL RESTRICTIONS OF
PHYSICS, TIME AND SPACE.
MORE A SPIRITUAL FORCE THAN
A TEMPORAL LEADER.
MORE A POET THAN A
POLITICIAN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE
AUTHOR OF OUR REDEMPTION,
BETO O'ROURKE.
>> BETO O'ROURKE THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PHENOM.
>> DESPITE HIS LOSS TO TED
CRUZ, THE ROCK AND ROLL
LOVING 46-YEAR-OLD CAUGHT
THE NATION'S ATTENTION.
♪ HIS OFFBEAT SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS APPEALING TO A YOUNGER
GENERATION.
EVEN TAKING A SKATEBOARDING
AT WHAT A BURGER.
HIS SENATE CANDIDACY WINNING
THE ENDORSEMENT OF
CELEBRITIES LIKE BEYONCE.
>> Tucker: BETO LOVES ROCK
AND ROLL SAYS GMA.
HE IS NOT LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE.
HE DOESN'T DO STUFFY
SPEECHES OR POLICY PROGRAMS.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BORE YOU
WITH ENTITLEMENT PROJECTIONS
OR SOME SCARY STUFF ABOUT
THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
BETO HAS A SKATEBOARD AND
WEARS NIRVANA T-SHIRTS HIS
VISION FOR THIS COUNTRY IS
1995.
S THAT THE YEAR HE WAS
LIVING WAY UPTOWN WALK UP
AND WORKING AS DUDE ON 112TH
STREET WITH.
SO STICKEST BUD IN
MANHATTAN,INDICA A GOOD
TIME.
BETO WANTS TO BRING US BACK
TO THAT TIME AND THE PRESS
IS TOTALLY ON BOARD.
>> I SAW HIM FOR THE FIRST
TIME A MONTH AGO WHEN HE SAT
DOWN WITH OPRAH AND ME AND
THE REST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE AUDIENCE THOUGHT WOW,
THIS GUY HAS THIS DYNAMIC,
POSITIVE ENERGY.
>> YEAH.
HE HAS THAT RAW TALENT.
IS HE VERY KIND OF
OBAMA-ESQUE INDEED.
>> WOMEN VOTED FOR HIM IN
THE SUBURBS OF HOUSTON WHO
HADN'T VOTED DEMOCRAT FOR
HAD BETO CRUSH GOING ON.
>> HE HAS THAT MAGIC HIS SON
IS NAMED ULIS CEASE.
>> GLEAM IN HIS EYE.
EVAN SMITH IN THE TEXAS
TRIBUNE SEEING HIM LIKE A
JESUS CHRIST SUPER STAR
SEEING THIS GUY IN FRONT OF
PEOPLE.
HE HAS THAT CELEBRITY ORA
ABOUT HIM AND IN THAT MOMENT
HE WAS OWNING THAT.
>> YOU HEARD IT BETO HAS
THAT MAGIC DUST OH, YEAH HE
DOES AT LEAST AN 8 BALL.
THE GUY ON 112TH STREET HAS
MORE IF YOU NEED IT.
GREAT HAIR, TOO.
BEAT THAT COMBO.
ACTUAL VOTING DOESN'T BEGIN
FOR MONTHS BUT BETO IS
ALREADY AMERICA'S SPIRITUAL
PRESIDENT.
AND BY THE WAY THAT'S A MUCH
CLEANER WAY TO RUN FOR
OFFICE.
REAL ELECTIONS THE ONES WITH
VOTERS SOMETIMES END LIKE
THIS.
>> SO WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
BIG NEWS TO REPORT.
WE CAN CALL NOW THAT THE
TEXAS RACE WILL GO TO TED
CRUZ, THE INCUMBENT
REPUBLICAN.
>> THE TED CRUZ WIN OVER
BETO O'ROURKE SIGNIFICANT.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT
ELECTION WAS A BUMMER.
SO BETO SPLIT SOON AFTER ON
A SOLO ROAD TRIP.
IT WAS A WHOLE ME AND YOU
AND A DOG NAMED BOO KIND OF
THING.
THE SORT OF TRIP THAT
STEINBECK WOULD HAVE TAKEN,
A HUM OF THE ENGINE AND
BLACK RIB OF THE OPEN ROAD
TIME TO FEED THE SOUL ALSO A
TIME TO STAGE A SERIES OF
PUBLICITY SHOTS FOR SNAPCHAT
AND INSTAGRAM BLOGGING THE
WHOLE THING TIMELESS STUFF
ALL-AMERICAN REDEMPTION
STORY.
BETO CAME BACK A BETTER MAN.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT THING WAS NOT
FOR HIM.
>> IS THERE A SCENARIO WHERE
YOU RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2020 OR BEYOND?
>> NO.
>> NO?
>> UNEQUIVOCALLY YOU WILL
NEVER RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> NO PUNTO, NO PERIOD.
>> Tucker: NO PUNTO WHERE
PEOPLE ARE AUTHENTIC AND
SPEAK VARIOUS LANGUAGES AT
ONCE.
>> YES I AM HIRING A STAFF
AS SOON AS I CAN FIND
BILLIONAIRES.
FOR NOW I WILL LIE ABOUT MY
PLANS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT BETO
DID.
HERE WE ARE IN THE AGE OF
BETO.
WHAT'S THE PLAN, MAN?
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WHAT'S NEXT?
WHAT'S NEXT BETO SAYS IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
THINGS THAT WE THINK OF AS
TERRIFYING THREATS TO THE
COUNTRY ARE ACTUALLY
PERFECTLY COOL.
LIKE MORE THAN 20 MILLION
PEOPLE USING FAKE IDENTITIES
TO LIVE ILLEGALLY INSIDE THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE BEST, MAN.
>> ALL OF US, WHEREVER YOU
LIVE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE IF
IMMIGRATION IS A PROBLEM
IT'S THE BEST POSSIBLE
PROBLEM FOR THIS COUNTRY TO
HAVE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT'S THE
BEST PROBLEM.
HARD TO THINK OF A BETTER
PROBLEM.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS SUCH
A COOL PROBLEM TO HAVE, WE
OUGHT TO HAVE MORE.
LET'S KNOCK DOWN THE BORDER
WALL, DUDE.
>> IF YOU COULD, WOULD YOU
TAKE THE WALL DOWN NOW HERE.
>> YES.
>> LIKE YOU HAVE A WALL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> KNOCK IT DOWN.
>> I WOULD TAKE THE WALL
DOWN.
>> DO YOU THINK IF THERE IS
A REFERENDUM HERE ON THIS
CITY THAT WOULD PASS?
>> I DO.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IT'S FINE.
BUT THAT'S NOT TO SAY BETO
DOESN'T SEE PROBLEMS ON THE
HORIZON.
HE DOES.
AND WHEN HE DOES, HIS DOUGH
BROWN EYES CLOUD A LITTLE
AND HE STARES OFF IN THE
DISTANCE TO CONSIDER
HOLISTIC SOLUTION JUST LIKE
JAMES DEAN WOULD HAVE DONE
IF HE WOULD LIVED TO BE
BETO'S AGE AND COULD
SKATEBOARD.
GLOBAL WARMING COULD MAKE US
GOICS TICKET LIKE THE
DINOSAURS IN THE MUSEUM,
DEAD FOREVER.
>> SOME WILL CRITICIZE THE
NEIL FOR BEING TOO BOLD OR
BEING UNMANAGEABLE.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING BETTER
THAT ADDRESSES THE SINGULAR
CRISIS THAT WE FACE, A
CRISIS THAT COULD, AS ITS
WORSE LEAD TO EXTINCTION.
>> Tucker: EXTINCTION,
THAT'S WHAT BETO IS FIGHTING
AGAINST.
WHAT ELSE IS HE FOR?
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION BUT
HONESTLY IT'S NOT REALLY
CLEAR.
WE CHECKED HIS CAMPAIGN
WEBSITE THERE IS A PICTURE
THAT SAYS BETO FOR AMERICA
IN ENGLISH THE WON IN
SPANISH SAYS BETO FOR ALL.
THEY COULDN'T FIND ANY
ACTUAL POLICIES EVEN ABOUT
FIGHTING EXTINCTION WE DID